we are live
because these are some very sad times
that we're living in
we have the oppression that is going on
as we speak
you have innocent men women and children
just being blown to pieces
so we want to get a kind of a background
on what's going on we have
a good friend of ours stanford pass who
we're going to be bringing on
right now he's going to kind of get into
his just a little bit condensed version
we've had him on the show before
comes from a jewish background born into
a jewish family
and he has a good deep understanding of
the history in that area
and let me bring him on so he can kind
of uh take a
take off from here with the rest how are
you stanford pass
eddie peace be with you i'm as good as
as good as i can be under the
circumstances by the grace of allah yeah
yeah it's very nice to uh have you on
with us
uh just for the for the people that
don't know a little bit about your
history
and your background can you tell us i
mentioned that you come from a jewish
background born in a jewish family
yeah i was born 72 years ago into a
jewish family
when i was 14 years old kennedy got
killed i put me on a path to look for
the truth
i didn't stop looking um i found out
about all the false flags during my life
when 9 11 happened i started speaking up
against
uh people persecuting muslims because i
realized it couldn't have happened that
way
people said what are you defending
muslims for i said i don't even know any
muslims i'm defending the truth here
and in 2009 allah let me home a lot let
me
become muslim uh made me realize that it
is all one story
and that all the prophets and messengers
came from the same place and it's all
about monotheism
and um and we even we we believe jesus
is coming back we just don't worship him
that's all that's interesting uh you
have one of your
posts here and i'll share it you see it
here
yep can you share this uh your thoughts
uh when you posted this
he's going back and guess who's
palestinian
jesus christ prophet isa peace be upon
him who
people call jesus uh
it's ironic because there's no jay in
aramaic or hebrew but that's another
you know they got his name wrong and the
story wrong his name is
isa or yeshua and he is palestinian
and he is coming back and
i think everything else pretty much
speaks for itself um
these are his people these are his these
are his these are his homies
these are his people this is where he's
from this is his neighborhood
this is his homeland that they're
tearing up
uh talking just a couple of weeks ago
israel is going to hurt
lebanese civilians to include kids of
the family
we went through a very long discussion
we did it then
we did it in the gaza strip we are going
to do it in any round of hostilities in
the future
that's the defense minister this is the
uh
military chief of staff benny ganz the
next round of violence
will be worse and see this suffering
increase
he headed up the military assaults on
gaza the last
two this is the minister for education
in the netanyahu government there will
never be a peace plan with the
palestinians
i will do everything in my power to make
sure they never
get a state he also said
if you catch terrorists you simply have
to kill them
i've killed a lot of arabs in my life
and there's no problem with that
uh this is the minister for justice
palestinians are all enemy combatants
this also includes the mother the
mothers of the martyrs
they should follow their sons nothing
would be more just
they should go as should the physical
homes in which
uh what do you think that uh video came
in as we were speaking
this is the irish mp i don't know if you
had a chance to see that
uh we'll get back to it but what do you
what do you think is your first time
hearing this
first time i've heard this i've heard
all of these accusations
and and proofs before i didn't hear it
from the irish
before and may allah bless them for
speaking defense ministry
we got to back up
did you want to go yeah we'll go ahead
and finish it here together and then get
your thoughts on you're out
okay that's the israeli minister for
justice in the last few months
the israeli minister for a deputy
minister for defence
palestinians are beasts they are not
human uh the minister for foreign
affairs
cp hotline is the last one so this is uh
as we're talking this is a an actual uh
uh politician a mp this is somebody of
some um
integrity somebody who's in a high
position who's speaking out
you know for truth like what you were
interested in you know and still are
truth and it didn't matter you know who
you were speaking
to or against you just wanted to get the
truth out what do you think when you
hear this
person this irish mp not scared to
uh and he's he's not making this stuff
up these are
quotes that he's quoting from p other uh
politicians in that area
we need more people like him in the
world coming out and speaking
up no matter who they are where they're
from to do you know to speak up for the
truth
you know people who love god people god
loves those who love the truth
whatever wherever they're from whatever
they believe wherever they're coming
from
and god loves an honest disbeliever more
than a hypocritical believer too
so it's time for people to stand up and
start talking
people are committing atrocities in
broad daylight
you know what started me off on this was
a president getting his head blown off
on television
and they got away with that and look at
us look at us now
look at what they're doing now in broad
daylight they took
to let don't get me started with the
world trade center
okay but anyway um the point of it is
eddie
that the zionist congress of 1897
decided to take palestine okay
that's when they decided to take
palestine in 1897 that was 120
324 years ago hitler was eight years old
this has nothing to do with world war ii
or the sympathy for the world
for the holocaust i mean my heart goes
out to all the people that suffered in
world war ii
but zionism has nothing to do with it
they're using it
they're using it as a red-hairing
argument to to justify what they're
doing now
they decided in 1897 to take palestine
when hitler was eight years old
this thing is long and they never
intended to keep the balfour
declaration to keep their word that was
just their foot in the door
they got into palestine the following
way can i
go on a little rant here eddie yeah yes
uh go ahead
okay during world war all right first of
all
the khazarian jews the middle ages in
the when the khazarians were
were grafted into the jewish uh religion
for a political reason by a king over in
the black or caspian sea area a place
called gazaria
um this there was an element of people
within that group
who were just hell-bent on just being in
charge of whatever they were in they
were just wanted to own everything run
everything
do everything that wasn't all of them
but there was an element within the
group
they never were able to land at a home
and be welcomed because of this
germany took them in they flourished in
germany
music art medicine philosophy everything
they flourished in germany
when world war one broke out
this group of people who become the
zionists the rothschilds came out of
them they were goldsmiths who became
money lenders
who became money lenders to countries
who realized they had all the power
they controlled the money they own all
the central banks in the world now
but i digress let me get back to the
point here
when when uh the when the uh
at the very when this got started they
decided to
i lost my when i started talking about
the ross child i got off on a second
um
just give me one second no no worries uh
we're gonna get get
uh we'll continue uh when you find your
place
please let us know we're gonna go ahead
and um
continue on with this here my position
is that between the sea and the jordan
river
there needs to be one state only the
state of israel
there is no place for any agreement of
any kind that discusses the concession
of israeli sovereignty
over lands conquered in 1967.
did you find your place yeah i got it go
ahead when world war
one began okay uh the zionists
the people who were who were um
that element of the khazarian ashkenazi
eastern european jewish converts
went to england after the zionist
congress and they said
we want palestine because somehow
england had some kind of mandate or
control of the middle eastern area
and england said well what are we going
to what's in it for us
and the the german zionists
who had been welcomed into germany said
if we can get the united states into
world war
one to beat germany and for you to be
victorious
will you give us palestine and and
england said sure
so the german zionists went to the
united states
and got world war and got the united
states involved in world war one
and germany was flattened after world
war one
okay and that's what happened and that's
why
germany developed such a hatred for jews
which most
jews have no idea about i'm not
justifying what happened
to the civilians in world war ii i'm
just saying this is the roots of it
and the fact is that that palestine was
a pawn
that that the rothschild family wanted
palestine theodore herzl wanted to go to
argentina
but the rothschilds you know money talks
so they got they got palestine
you know beachfront property the
mediterranean they wanted to run the
world
the bankers want to run the world from a
beachfront mediterranean property
maybe have donald trump run the golf
courses you know
we'll uh we'll continue on here and then
we'll we'll get some more from
some of the history that you're talking
about yeah the official statements of
several ministers
of the current government of israel
in one case actually advocating genocide
of all palestinians including children
and calling them
snakes now can i ask you t-shock
do you not think that if we're defining
terrorism
that is the language and thinking of
terrorists
that is absolutely unacceptable in
civilized politics in civilized
international relations
for the heads of government of a state
that we
carry on normal relations with and who
you met
in paris to advocate those sort of views
when we know they have also led on to
the deaths of thousands of palestinians
uh innocent child men women and children
what have you to say tasha
about those sort of views being
expressed by the israeli government
what are your thoughts on what he is
he's nailing it he's just he's totally
putting them he's putting their feet to
the fire
this man is brave and he's telling the
truth um
the whole the whole idea that this was a
plan since 1897
um shows like the they had a pre
way premeditation to do this this is not
a knee jerk to world war ii
or the poor jews that came out of europe
or any of that they had a plan
way deep deeper than that and the
balfour declaration which i sent you a
copy of
they had never people palestine
people go ahead keep going it was no
intention for them to keep the balfour
declaration in good faith
that was just their foot in the door
because i sent you another graphic from
hayam weitzman in 1920 three years after
the balfour declaration which was very
arrogant
and basically said we're coming and
whether you like it or not
this was their plan since 1897 what you
see
on the board right now is this is their
plan to expand
the two blue lines and the israeli flag
are the nile and the euphrates
that's the two blue lines in the flag of
israel and the
and the star is this rothschild star not
the star of david
it was the shield of the rothschilds
business back in the day
only it was red rothschild was a red
star
but it became a blue one anyway that's
that was their plant from square one was
this greater israel
that's what it's you know i was a little
kid in the 50s looking at a 13 inch
black and white tv
watching the mideast crisis in black and
white since i was since i was a
you know knee-high to a table you know
and i've been watching this all my life
and that's what i didn't know about this
until i was almost
what in my in my senior years i didn't
know about this
my parents didn't know a lot of good
jews in america had no idea
were both your father and mother uh
jewish yes
and they were supporting they were
snowed and so were so most of the
american jews
were guilted and snowed into supporting
israel
with the whole violin music and feel
sorry for the jews from world war
ii when really they were just using that
as a
as a sheep's clothing to
do this which has nothing to yeah
which has nothing to do with the with
the religion of moses
or the jewish people or anything this is
something else
now what would you um let me hear your
response to
their particular jews i believe this is
a
rabbi i've had rabbi weiss on the
program i don't know if you've heard of
him
and others like mikko pillaid his uh
father was um
yeah i heard him yesterday you heard me
okay yeah his father was
a general in the israeli army his
great-grandfather
was also someone who was a signer of the
declaration of independence for israel
but he's on the side of justice the side
of truth so are these
jews so this is not something that it's
muslims uh verse
jews uh arab verse palestinian
uh this is just about justice and truth
uh yes you think here
this is the people of palestine they
should know it's
we feel very shame what's going on there
especially they're doing
everything in our name in the name of
jews in the name of the torah
in the name of god it's so shameful we
are with you you have to know
the zionists are strong we are weak
but god is on our side at the end of the
day
the palestinian flag will be
on all palestine from the river to the
sea
wow what do you what do you think of
that i think he's uh another one telling
the truth
um what kind of jews are these here that
are speaking out against this uh
oppression and
i don't know they're sect but i know
that they're orthodox
meaning that i know god didn't create
orthodox conservative in reform
allah created you know he gave the word
down and these folks are trying to
adhere to the torah
which is which is the book of guidance
and they're trying to
follow the book of guidance the best
they can and they know
from doing that that what's going on in
the name of judaism
by the zionists is a total fraud it's a
total lie
you know for the jews for netanyahu to
stand there and say we re
represent all the jews in the world is a
big lie
and he has a lot of stinking nerve to
say that um
that's all have you ever been laid this
label this term here
oh yeah i've been i've been labeling
this semantic a lot especially by
some of the people that were closest to
me um
because you know that's that's just the
way it goes
unfortunately a lot of ignorant people
have a hatred a blind hatred for
different people
jews or whatever other kind of people
too but when you get down to why that
hatred began
actually theodore herzl used
anti-semitism as a way for fundraising
this was a tool that was used to
um and again as i mentioned about world
war one
and the zionist german zionists getting
united states into world war one to
flatten germany
um they didn't uh there wasn't they did
the germans didn't hate the jews because
of their high
intellect or they were jealous of them
or any of that they hated them because
they
sold them out in world war one and
germany was totally decimated
that's why they didn't like them uh up
until then they were getting along great
they were getting along great there's a
rich history i mean for a thousand
over a thousand years uh isn't it right
that the golden ages
for the jewish people was living in
spain andalus
when the muslims were ruling they were
can you talk about this
i don't know that much about it but i
know that the there was a
a renaissance before the renaissance and
the renaissance that we learned in
school as americans the european
renaissance
was built on the shoulders of the
islamic empire
which was destroyed and
built upon you know that they stole a
lot of things and burnt a lot of things
and took a lot of things
and plagiarized um but i i'm not i'm not
a scholar or well-versed in on to loose
knowledge or history um but i did want
to say
that um allah is using me
you know he he gave me the life he gave
me he led me through judaism
christianity a lot of other things and
to be a muslim
then he put me with then i came to
substitute somebody
at one of your interviews in new jersey
i was asked to just stand in because
somebody couldn't make it
and then you interviewed me again and
without looking for it i got
i got people looking at me and then
because of that
this woman came to me in december who's
in gaza
on facebook she came to me and she said
can you help me
and sister nevin is in gaza she's a
single mother with four little children
a brother a lie brother and a brother
who was killed and a sick mother
and right now they're dropping bombs on
her and her family
and she's she's she's got nothing but
the rope of allah
because it all depends where allah
allows those bombs to drop
people are being buried under buildings
they've had to run from place to place
and this all started back in december
when all we were trying to do was help
them buy a food cart
so they could go sell coffee at the bus
stop so they could make some money
and this is why you know they wanted to
just be they were they didn't want a
handout
they wanted to become you know
self-sufficient
so we were just trying to help them and
one thing's led to another and now
the pat the fact is now we need leaders
to stand up
and to say israel stop you know
i agree that terrorism is wrong it's a
sin
the the jews that were killed by those
rockets it's a sin
i agree but i ask everybody who's
critical
what would you do if somebody came to
your door and threw you out of your
house and said you had to leave
because it's in the bible and there's
this armed people and there's army
behind them to back them up
what would any of you do what would you
do
uh is this one of uh of the many posts
is this one also can you go ahead
because some people hide behind that
all the atrocities and you have actually
have some christians also who
who will go ahead and condone what's
happening the oppression against the
innocent totally baffles me how the
christians hate muslims and love the
jews
when the jews rejected jesus and the
muslims love jesus i
it's a total it's a total ox uh what do
you call it cognitive dissonance
because these are the words allegedly in
the bible
that jesus christ said that you just had
up there and he's telling the children
of israel
he's basically telling him the covenant
is going to be broken
the covenant is going to be broken all
right there are no more the chosen
people
and the people of monotheism would be
given to people who would honor it
okay it's my belief nobody told me this
and i didn't read it anywhere but it's
just my firm belief
having been a muslim 12 years that the
muslims have the covenant now
we are the custodians of monotheism in
this world
as a group and and we're keeping
monotheism alive on earth right now
because it sure as heck the the zionists
aren't doing it
and uh the christians are worshiping
jesus and three and
everything so muslims are holding the
fort for monotheism right now and have
been
for 1442 years
yeah i want to make that point uh when
we talked about for over a thousand
years you had the golden age
of the jews so this is not a jewish
muslim thing i mean you had muslims and
jews before all of this
they were getting along quite fine i
mean so you never had in this thousand
years where you had
now muslims attacking jews or whatnot
you even have you know people
such as uh the professor david
war weinstein he's an academic he's a
jewish professor
uh in history and he quotes that
islam saved the jury so this is not
coming from muslims i mean
this is coming from jewish scholars so
when you look at
this jews were always welcome they fled
persecution they came into muslim lands
you even had at the time you had the
bessa
this is the from the albanian saying
that you know
where the albanians bosnians anywhere
that jews went
uh by muslims you know they were welcome
they were taken care of
you know they they fled christian
persecution they came to muslim land so
now when the tables it's
ironic when the tables are turned you
have
uh the zionists so we differentiate you
have
jews just like this rabbi was coming out
just like i had
you know miko pillett and others who are
against this
but right you have this zionist movement
and would you say the zionist movement
is more like it's
it's more of a secular atheist movement
void of god
i believe that i believe the zionist
movement um
contains a certain amount of demonic uh
energy in it and
um uh they worship
they worship the material plane then
there's the freemasons who worship
lucifer
uh pretty much they believe that
lucifer's like the
you know it's like when you have a
family and the father's an old
an old grumpy old man and and the oldest
son is trying to
like save the rest of the family from
his grumpiness
so he's going to enlighten the younger
children the younger brothers and
sisters
this is what they believe they believe
the old god is like some old you know
out of date and lucifer is going to
enlighten the human race this is
like uh what's his name albert pike and
morals and dogma
the freemasons and so forth and zionism
is
has a relationship with them
i just sent you a picture
i just sent you a picture eddie of an
arab an old arab man and an old jewish
man walking hand in hand
this was in 1923 before the zionists
like
got their claws in too deep i sent you a
picture just now if you have it
uh this is uh this is something that
we're talking about and this is where uh
good human beings need to step up no
matter yes you're jewish
no matter if you're christian you know
to stand up against injustices and now
you can see what happened because
in the human being god almighty has put
in all of us
this innate nature to to want to do good
to stand
to be on the side of justice you know
and uh it's not
a coincidence now this is an israeli
soldier who's
done uh some of this ethnic cleansing
who's committed some of these crimes and
look what happens to the soul
just pay attention this is very
interesting us
sanford pay attention to this yes
he comes to me did you hear that the
person that is the person that he killed
comes to him and said
why did you kill he's like going crazy
now look how and
what do you what do you think about when
you hear that i feel like allah is
is turning this person's heart and
making him turning him into an agent of
good
and he's choosing to use this man to to
be a
vehicle for the truth and this is this
is uh
you know we need you know this is this
is what needs to be heard more
and um it just it makes me feel
you know this is a lot chooses who he
will
to to you know carry the truth
but
that man is the most successful person
in that room
because allah is touching him allah is
making him
awake even though it's painful and even
though it's
suffering he's the he's the most
conscious person in that room
and and even though he's hurting you
know
and and may allah guide him may allah
guide him the rest of the way
to the truth you know
he talks about your whole system has
failed he talks about you know the
post-traumatic stress that he's having
he's living a nightmare because
i mean there's a verse in the quran you
know it chapter 5 verse 32 killing
one innocent human being is as as though
you killed
the world this is the sanctity of human
life it doesn't matter what nationality
raised color you're from
i mean this is one of the things that
when you come on the day of judgement
you know and if we firmly believe this
is what jesus
he warned people of the hell fire the
consequences of doing
the oppression on earth you're going to
have to be you're going to be held
account and now people come with
innocent you know you got kids
in gaza now you got bombs just falling
and
you know blowing up innocent children uh
into
in thousands of pieces you know and and
this is a result you'll see how many
more people like this
you know they think they can go home and
sleep you know
freely without you know uh the kind of
traumas that are happening
to them this is you know so people need
to uh
like you talk about be awoke wake wake
up to this speak
speak uh out you know and let the truth
be heard
i might have a message for jews message
for jews
if you saw the movie avatar
i call this having a jake sully moment
jake sully was a
wheelie he was in a wheelchair and in
that movie
if you saw it they were able to put
their consciousness into a
a cloned uh blue big blue creature of
this planet where they were trying to
strip
the resources and what this what the
wheelie jake sully realized
is that the blue people weren't the
savages his own species were the savages
and he and this is what i call the jake
sully moment when you
decide you're going to go with the truth
and not make a racist decision
to stay with your species or your race
just for the sake of staying
with your species or your race because
when we get to the
when we get to our exit
only in interview to gain time only in
order to strengthen them go ahead can
you
when i just heard a voice so i stopped
when we get to our exit interview
you know allah's not going to be
interested in anything else
but you know what we were up to what we
were doing you know it's not going to be
like left or right it's going to be us
and him
and we have to answer he gave us brains
he gave us brains
we can't say oh somebody else told me to
do it no
he gave us brains this my first imam
taught me this
yeah even with anima you know because
even as a muslim
you have a question about your religion
about your deen you can you could ask 10
different imams and you could get 10
different opinions
and they could all be right too and
maybe one could be out
man could be outside of the boundary you
don't know but the thing is
at the end of the day allah gave you a
brain and when you're standing before
allah and he says why'd you do that
you have to be able to answer from your
own brain you can't defer to someone
else's brain
if your brain is functioning you're
responsible to use it
and you have to use it in this situation
because
there's it's just you know and there's
another movie
if uh in the media in the american what
do you call it culture
there's another movie called the usual
suspects
and in that movie there's a a being
called kaiser soze
who is a very feared being he's just a
terrible
feared creature of a human being
terrible barbaric you know everybody
they heard his name they
wet their pants you know and there was
this guy in the movie
kevin spacey played him verbal and he
was this crippled little guy
and everybody mocked him and made fun of
him and he walked with a limp and his
hand was shrunken up
and in the end he was he was kaiser soze
and i'm maintaining that the the mind
the the hacked
id the hacked id of the jewish people
that benjamin that the zionist
government is trying to promote
is the victim monster the kaiser soze of
this world
in reality one minute they're the victim
and the next minute when you're not
looking
they're the monster and this is who they
are and you have to know this and this
is not anti-semitism
this is anti-zionism and it's not the
same thing no matter what they say
they can weld it together with a
blowtorch it's not the same thing
can you uh talk about do you know
because many people don't understand
the uh current plight of
the palestinians there the muslims even
christians who are palestinians they
also suffer at the hands of this
injustice you know
okay just stop just off the bat you know
some of the laws for instance let me
give you for instance
in gaza where sister nevin is with her
family
the jews the the the zionists i don't
want to say the jews because this is
they mix up the political agenda with
the religion
the zionists
destroyed the uh infrastructure
back in 2005 in gaza
and then they sabotaged any event any
attempt to rebuild it
the electrical grid um and they
didn't allow the experts to go in they
didn't allow raw materials to go in i
did a little research
because the israelis were all pointing
fingers at the palestinian management
saying
you guys just don't know how to manage
your electrical system
and that's not the truth the truth is
the zionists
sabotaged it back 15 20 years ago
and did not allow it to be rebuilt and
that's why
sister nevin was only getting eight
hours of electricity a day
okay food was rotting kids were getting
food poisoning
we got him a new refrigerator right
before all this stuff started happening
we got him a new fridge she'd been to
the hospital a couple of times
with such with medical emergencies
her brother broke his hand in the shower
because they didn't even have a mat in
the shower
so many things happened but what i'm i
don't want to get into the
what i'm saying is that that gaza has
been
an open-air penitentiary basically
there's nowhere to go
they got the ocean and they got the
fences and there's nowhere to go
and they and their electricity was down
to eight hours a day
in this latest bombing thing they blew
up the the
transformers they blew up all the
electricity in gaza
there is no electricity that i know of
in gaza
people food is rotting children are
hungry people are getting sick
there's no light at night except
whatever battery operated things there
are
p and then they're terrified because
they got f-35s flying over
which are like the porsche of fighter
jets
which the united states provides and
benjamin netanyahu
says biden is supporting it because he's
got the f-35s
that's why i want americans to stand up
i sent you a link eddie
that any american can contact all of
their elected
officials with one stroke of a keypad
or a keyboard or whatever i sent you the
link for that
contact your politicians um for all
americans to do this
whenever you have a chance to where can
people they
what what uh for people who won't get
that link where we can put that up uh
it's
contact what's the url i think i
i sent it over to you i i can't i gotta
look i'll have to look it up right now
to find it but i think
we'll pull it up yeah we'll put it up so
this is
yeah okay you have it but anyway
americans can like
can can i send a video you know how joe
biden says come on
i i told joe biden to come on on video i
said come on
people are dying over there i said let's
see what he does about it
he said he's a zionist he says i'm not a
jew but i'm a zionist
you know they're all this all these
politicians are pretty much the same
when you boil it down
because they're all answering to israel
the one who stands up and says no to
israel
the last one i know of got his head
blown off in 1963
he wouldn't he didn't want to give
nuclear power to israel
and when when kennedy got killed they
tripled the nuclear
the money to go to israel for their
nuclear program
so once uh again this is not about
jewish muslim let's just clear that myth
because
no academic as the academic professor
david orenstein in his paper islam
saved the jury so when muslims were
ruling
when jews were living with muslims
they had their full rights they were
able to prosper
they were able to grow uh this is
against injustice you have
we're commanded we're commanded to live
in peace with anybody who wants to live
in peace with us
yeah this is from allah so what advice
would you have for people who
are just kind of confused you know they
read the headlines
and they see that okay um you know
they're getting
the spin of the story they're not
understanding you know
the real history and what's going on on
there the injustices
the open-air prism where people are
living in the lack of food water basic
human necessities the basic
rights that a human has you know they're
been taken away
and nobody would stand for it here you
know imagine
you know should that person because he's
palestinian muslim have to
stand for it there you know what what
advice where people get there's a great
documentary called
occupation 101 it's on youtube
occupation 101.
uh anything else for people who are
hearing this for the first time
and get they want to learn more you know
haters are going to hate eddie
you know you could you could like in
surah baqarah you could talk to some
people till you're blue in the face and
then nothing's going to change them
but there might be that one person
sitting in the back just taking it all
in who's gonna
it's gonna change their life and all
you're gonna do is just keep keep
letting your light shine and keep
telling the truth
and whoever preaches a word that means
god uh
broadcast and you are a preacher because
you're broadcasting
your visit you're really you're actually
whoever's broadcasting
all right you broadcast and when you
broadcast people have a
choice to pick up the frequency or not
and that's up to
them and up to allah who here whose
heart is open and who hears this
and it's you know we're getting up to
the money shot this you know this is the
time we're getting so close to the time
before the hour
this is you know muslims need to
understand
and and really this is i'm talking to
somebody every day now who could die the
next moment
and then again they could outlive me i
could die the next moment too
but their probability if you look at the
the odds
which there aren't any because everybody
goes when a lot takes them
i could i could sneeze now and bust a
capillary and die but
the fact is that they're under bombing
right now and
to be in contact with these people and
to be
having contact with them for eight
months and to have developed emotional
ties she calls me father
she calls me father and
lately i've been calling her daughter
now because i want her to know
you know that she's loved and and that
she i guess she didn't have one that
loved her or
he's gone or he didn't love her or
something because she calls me father
and and i have a responsibility to to
at least from my heart be a father to
her if i can't do it any other way just
to be there
and and it's it's we know that martyrs
are
successful and they go straight to jenna
and they don't stand on the day of
judgment and we know that it's a
you know they're like the rock stars of
paradise the martyrs are the
treated first class i know that but it
hurts on the way
it hurts on the way and and uh i just
ask a lot to protect them
and all the people that are going
through it not only in palestine but in
yemen and in
and in china and and all the other
places where it's going on
you know we're in the time before the
hour and you know what the dajjal
the antichrist hasn't even shown up yet
okay it's going to get worse before it
gets better
we have to understand this and as my
father used to say
may allah light his grave and and bless
his heart for making the shahada before
he died
at 95 a jew all his life you know
he said when times get like this it's
time to buckle down
it's just time to buckle down get
serious you know there was a imam in in
new jersey
when trump got elected and he said to
the brothers he said to all the muslims
in the he said
what do we do what do we do trump's
elected he says you do what you do what
you do
you do your salat you do your psalm
you in other words you do your you be
muslim that's what you do and that's
what we do now
only we do it in earnest we need to do
it in earnest we need to do it with with
gusto we need to turbo boost our iman
we need to strengthen our iman by pr by
obeying allah
praying on time speaking the truth
uncomfortable
doing all obeying allah will give us the
energy
that we need to do what we have to do
because it all comes from him
so if we hook into the source of energy
and we do what he tells us to do what
the source tells us to do
then he will give us what we need to do
what we need to do
thank you so much that's all i can say
and if i since i can't
you know i got to say i you know i
watched the
shows artsagal and osman the uh the
stories about urtugal and osman uh
the turkish series about our 12th
century
ancestors in islam who kept islam alive
in anatolia
during when the byzantines and the
mongols were going at each other
and the muslims are right in the middle
and
it's the same as it ever was because you
got the byzantines you got the western
world and you got the mongols you got
the eastern world
and you got the muslims in the middle
and the same stories going on
as was going on then and and it and we
just have to realize that
you know we can't pick up a sword
anymore and go in a field and do our
business
and sometimes i wish i could but that's
not where we're at in history right now
so i can't do anything physically but i
can speak
god gave me a mouth to speak with and a
brain to think with and a heart to feel
with
and i'm using everything in my power to
do
what allah wants me to do at a time like
this and i
advise and i for the god's sake don't
whoever is listening to this don't go oh
look at him oh look oh
boomer oh jazakallah no do it yourself
do it [ __ ] do it don't make the same
mistake
you know with everybody who steps up and
tells the truth everybody puts them on a
pedestal don't
put anybody on a pedestal muhammad peace
be upon him
wouldn't even have pictures don't do to
me what you did to jesus
don't do to leaders what you do to other
leaders
be one yourself be one yourself
everybody
it's time for everybody to speak up
everybody
every human being who loves the truth if
you love the truth speak up
stand for past brother thank you very
much we started with peace we are with
peace keep
our brothers and sisters palestine all
over the world those who are suffering
who are being impressed in your duas
thank you brother jazakallah salaam
alaikum alaikum